welcome to the man of recaps this is
attack on titan full series recap
leading up to season 4 part 2 the final
chapter 100 years ago the titans
appeared they're naked creepy-looking
man-eating giants that hunted humans
almost to extinction but some survivors
managed to build enormous walls so the
last remnants of humanity are all
trapped here and the walls work
extremely well they're way taller than
any titan so for the last hundred years
humanity's had a relatively peaceful
happy existence but some people are not
happy like our main character aaron
yeager who hates that humanities penned
in here like cattle aaron is a real
angry kid who likes to yell a lot his
best friend armin is a smart kid who
likes to cry a lot and their other best
friend mikasa is the strong silent type
who's there to keep aaron in line one
day everything changes when an
absolutely massive colossal titan
appears this thing is taller than the
walls and it kicks open the gate letting
the titans inside it is a slaughter and
while aaron and friends are carried to
safety his mother is left behind and
aaron watches as his mom is devoured by
a titan his hometown of shiganchina is
destroyed but it was on a little knobby
outside the walls with the dual gate
system so the interior gate is still
intact until another abnormal titan
appears this one unarmored titan and oh
it charges the gate boom bursts it wide
open now the titans are flooding into
walmaria and the entire outer ring the
bulk of humanity's land is lost aaron
yeager vows revenge she's going to kill
all the titans every last one so as soon
as he's old enough aaron joins the
military along with his best friends arm
and mikasa and he meets some new best
friends among the other recruits there's
connie who's bald sasha who's hungry and
jon who's kind of cocky becomes aaron's
rival now the humans fight titans in a
super cool way using odm gear
omnidirectional mobility units that
shoot out grappling hooks and let them
fly around you gotta get up high because
the titan's only weakness is at the nape
of their neck pretty soon eren's
training is almost complete but just
then the colossal titan appears again
but this time aaron yeager's ready to
fight back he gets up there ready to
take this thing out but just as quickly
as it appeared it vanishes what is going
on here but before it left it destroyed
the gate so now titans are pouring in
and it's up to our group of recruits to
fight them off it's time for their first
epic fight against the titans but oh
titans look kinda silly but they are way
faster and stronger it's not a fight
it's a massacre even our main character
aaron all gets his leg chomped harmon's
about to be eaten well there he goes but
oh aaron grabs him and gets him to
safety how's he gonna get out of this
one well he doesn't he's swallowed maybe
he's not the main character with aaron
out of the picture his friend mikasa
takes the spotlight she is by far the
best in the class she's a titan killing
natural her parents were killed when she
was young it was actually aaron who came
to save her but he failed and at this
moment something in her snapped she
understood that in this cruel world you
have to fight to survive so now make us
a ghost on a titan killing rampage until
her odm gear runs out of gas then things
are looking bleak but wait what's this
one titan attacks the other and now it's
his turn for a titan killing rampage
alright when he's finally defeated
something very strange happens at the
nape of his neck is aaron yeager what is
going on for reasons unknown aaron
didn't die but burst free turning into a
titan and not a mindless titan like the
others but one where he was in control
it might have something to do with his
father grisha yeager who five years ago
gave him a mysterious injection and the
key to a secret basement but that will
remain a mystery for the next 50
episodes now everyone is quite surprised
by aaron's transformation ability but
this once smart guy commander pixis
recognizes the opportunity here aaron
figures out he can transform by drawing
blood like biting himself so boom he's a
titan again he grabs a big old boulder
and uses it to plug the gate so this
time humanity has stood its ground so
now aaron yeager's given over to
commander erwin of the scout regiment
who's just a real smart good guy and
once they officially graduate all of
erin's friends join the scouts too the
strongest of the scouts is captain levi
who is an absolute titan-killing machine
and the smartest of the scouts is hanji
who's the scientist type trying to
figure out what titans even are so
pretty soon it's time for their first
mission into titan country the scouts
are the best of the best any one normal
titans no big deal but today a new
abnormal titan shows up the female titan
and now that we know erin can do it it's
pretty obvious someone's driving this
thing she makes a beeline right to aaron
trying to capture him but this whole
thing was a trap boom yeah they've got
her they had a suspicion there was a spy
in their ranks unfortunately she does
not stay trapped very long and goes on a
rampage killing all of aaron's new
friends so now aaron transforms too and
it's a titan fight but she has the
ability to harden certain parts of her
body and oh beats aaron handley captain
levi and mikasa give it everything
they've got to get aaron to safety now
one of their friends and fellow recruits
is annie and i don't want to jump to
conclusions but she looks exactly like
the female titan they lead her into a
trap but it doesn't work and she
transforms again it's titan fight round
two this time in the city and this time
aaron takes her down we might finally
get some answers but something
unexpected happens she hardens into a
crystal shell and that's where she stays
the rest of the series so in season two
our crew has earned some well-deserved
rest but titans appear within the walls
but where did they even come from the
walls were not breached but now our gang
is surrounded with them this time are
emir and krista amir's a real tough gal
and krista's real nice and amir has a
huge crush on krista she's like hey girl
i love you sorry about this secret she
leaps off the tower and cuts herself yes
emir can turn into a titan too how many
people can turn into titans what is
going on emir's titan is a weird little
gremlin one but she holds them off long
enough for reinforcements to arrive and
when she comes too hopefully we'll
finally get some answers we do solve one
mystery of where those titans came from
it seems like they started at connie's
hometown and one of them still stuck
there and there's just no denying it
that titan is connie's mom yes it seems
that all titans are people wow
but how and why was that village
transformed well it might have something
to do with the new abnormal they saw a
giant monkey man titan they named him
the beast titan but he didn't stick
around more on him later so now after
their latest brush with death our one
friend reina has had enough he's like yo
aaron me and bertolt are undercover
titans on a secret mission to capture
you so just come with us now and we'll
stop all the fighting um wait what yes
our friend ryna is the armored titan and
bear tolte is the colossal aaron's not
going without a fight so he and reina
doing some naked titan jujitsu while the
rest of the scouts try to take down
bertolt but the colossal's got a hot
steam defense mechanism they can't get
close he falls down to join the fight
and boom lands on aaron so they get him
and are out of there soon they have to
stop for rest though and by the way
anyone with titan powers can regenerate
any injury it'd be nice if we finally
got some answers on where these two came
from and what's going on but they don't
say nothing but when aaron yells at them
for breaking the wall and getting his
mom eaten they seem legitimately
remorseful they were just doing what
they had to do they brought him here
with them too though she wasn't with
them and she's not saying much either we
do get a vague part of her story for
reasons unknown she was turned into a
titan which was for many years a waking
nightmare but she stumbled upon reina
and bertolton and his undercover crew
and ate their fourth friend and
apparently if a normal titan eats
someone who has a titan transformation
power they'd turn back to human and now
get that power anyway the scouts catch
up to him so it's a big old chase with a
bunch of normal titans following
commander erwin's leading the charge but
doe gets his armpit off that doesn't
slow him down though in fact he busts in
to cut aaron free but now rhina's
chucking other titans at him it turns
into a whole mess and aaron yeager comes
face to face with the titan that ate his
mother he tries to transform but he
doesn't have the strength yet so he goes
to just punch this thing and oh it
actually works something unexpected has
happened for reasons unknown aaron can
now control other titans what is going
on so now the humans are able to escape
mir says goodbye to krista like hey girl
i love you but i think i should go with
them aaron doesn't keep his titan
controlling power it only worked at once
so once again we're left with more
questions than answers so season 3
begins with an unresolved mystery from
the start of season 2 there are titans
inside the walls what is going on the
high priest of the wall religion seems
to know something about it at first he
wasn't talking but eventually he agrees
to but now before he can he dies under
mysterious circumstances smells like a
government cover-up indeed the powers
that be have decided the scouts are
getting too close to the truth so they
have them all arrested on trumped-up
treason charges so for a while our crews
got to go into hiding as fugitives and
hunting them as an incredibly skilled
fighter it's kenny kenny the ripper he
and his crew use odm gear with guns
specifically trained to fight other
humans but there's still no match for
captain levi kenny himself though is a
match for levi in fact levi is his
nephew that he raised in the undercity
until one day he got bored and left
turns out kenny and levi are both
ackerman's who for a long time were the
bodyguards of the king something in
their genes make them incredibly strong
fighters which is why they're so much
better than everyone else and guess who
else's last name is ackerman it's mikasa
yes it's not by chance she's that
skilled it's in her blood so now the
government's going to execute commander
erwin and disband the scouts but the
rest of the military is like yeah nah
you guys are clearly corrupt they have a
little coup and the scouts names are
cleared but aaron yeager was captured
along with krista why her well turns out
her real name is astoria rice she's a
secret daughter of lord rice who turns
out is the true royal family so aaron's
chained up in a weird crystal cavern and
we actually finally get some answers the
royal family has the power of the
founding titan or the coordinate which
lets them control other titans that's
how the original king fritz built the
walls a hundred years ago they're made
out of hardened titans and the founding
titan has another power in the hands of
the royal family it can alter the memory
of the people that's why no one
remembers any history from before a
hundred years ago the royal family's
been keeping them in blissful ignorance
so for generations this founding titan
has been passed down through the royal
bloodline you inject yourself with a
thing turn into a titan eat your
ancestor and boom you're the new king
but five years ago aaron's father grisha
yeager crashed the ceremony and somehow
he had the power to turn into a titan
they had a titan fight but aaron's dad
won and ate the founding titan taking
the power for himself then he injected
young aaron who turned into a titan and
ate his dad and now had the power of
both those titans but why would he do
that we still don't know lord rice makes
him out to be a bad guy and he's like
historia you've gotta turn into a titan
eat your friend aaron and get the
founding titan back in the royal
bloodline then you can use the power to
control all the other titans and
humanity will be freed so that sounds
nice time to save the world but historia
realizes the hole in the story if the
royal family had this power for 100
years why did they never use it to stop
the titans well turns out along with the
founding titan comes the memories of the
original king fritz and whoever gets it
never explains why but is like oh yeah
no we gotta stay within the walls so it
becomes clear her dad does not have
humanity's best interest at heart he
just wants to hold on to power and his
story is like oh hell nah time to break
the cycle and free humanity from the god
king's rule meanwhile aaron's friends
are coming to rescue him they have an
awesome flying around fight versus kenny
and his crew but now a desperate lord
rice licks the titan potion which is not
how you're supposed to use it he turns
into a massive titan aaron and friends
are gonna be crushed but aaron found the
bottle it gives titans hardening power
and eats it so boom yeah now he makes a
hardened titan thing and saves them but
lord rice has turned into such a big
titan he can't even walk he crawls his
way to the nearest village and the
scouts gotta fight him they ramp some
gunpowder down his throat and boom
exploded so historia is crowned queen
but not bound to the will of her
ancestors and the day is saved now with
aaron's new hardening power he can
theoretically patch up holes in the wall
so for the first time humanity has a
chance to patch up the holes in
shiganshina and take back the outer ring
the scouts ride out in force and at
first the mission goes well but it was a
trap behind them a whole new crop of
titans pop up led by the beast titan we
briefly get to meet him his name is zeke
and he's ryan and bear told commander
and ryan is here too with the armored
titan but our scouts have a surprise for
him hanji has invented thunderspears
which are basically rocket launchers
which boom blow through his armor but
bear told you too with the power of the
colossal titan and the beast titans may
be the most dangerous he's a good
baseball player turns rocks into weapons
of mass destruction so commander erwin
leads a suicide charge and almost all
the scouts are wiped out but that bought
time for captain levi to sneak around
the back and oh takes the beast titan
out now lord rice had one more
titan-creating injection so if the
scouts can capture one of the
transforming titans alive they can take
that power but zeke is rescued by
another super weird titan who runs
around on all fours they call the kart
titan our gang blows up rhina but the
kart tine's there to rescue him too and
now it's armin who has the genius plan
to take out the colossal titan he goads
him into using a steam thing but he
holds on until oh sacrificing himself
but armin figured out using the steam
burns away the colossal's muscle mass
and it bought time for aaron back in
human form to sneak up behind and oh get
bertolt and armin is still alive just
barely it's like hey give him the titan
injection so it'll heal him and he can
eat bertolt get the colossal but turns
out commander erwin is also barely alive
and levi's got to choose which one to
save it becomes a heated debate but in
the end levi chooses erwin but with his
last breath commander erwin's like nah
let me die save the kid and so it's
armin who's turned into a titan eats
bertolt and now has the power of the
colossal and so it's an epic victory for
humanity they finally reclaimed their
outer ring but we still have no idea
what's really going on but now that they
can get to eren's old house in chigama
it's finally time to find out what's in
that cellar the mysterious key opens a
secret drawer which has books in it a
book with a photograph of aaron's father
and another family this is weird because
our people don't have photograph
technology turns out they're not the
last humans on earth there's a whole
world out there yes our walled city is
just on one little island they're next
to the empire of marley which is at like
early 1900s technology that's where
aaron's father is from but he's an
eldian a race that is horribly
discriminated against forced wear
armbands and living ghettos the official
story goes that queen yamir of the
aldians made a deal with the devil to
get titan powers and the old elden
empire used the power of the nine titans
that people could turn into to dominate
the world and they were awful and evil
but eventually there was a big war where
marley got eight of the nine titans and
defeated elder so the alien king fritz
fled with most of his people to the
island of parody paradise where he used
the power of the founding titan to build
the walls erases people's memories so
they could live in peace but many aliens
were left behind in marley where now
they're treated terribly because of
their devil blood and they've been
taught they deserve it because of the
sins of their ancestors they've got to
tone but when grisha yeager's little
sister is killed by marlene police he's
like oh hell nah we aliens deserve
better he grows up and joins the
underground aldi in resistance who
believes the official state history is a
lie they believe that queen emir and the
elden empire used the titans for good
but we just don't know the truth now
it's here grisham meets his first wife
who is a descendant of the royal
bloodline that was left behind so they
have a dream if they can take back the
power of the founding titan they can use
it to unleash the million titans that
make up the walls and stomp marley to
dust and the ld of royal blood who would
wield it is their son zeke yes the beast
titan is aaron's half-brother so
marley's ignored parodies for 100 years
but now they've found out there's oil
there which is all the more important in
the modern world and marley recruits
aliens into their army because they're
the only ones that can use the power of
the titans that's who ryan and bertolt
and annie were eldian warriors fighting
for marley so dr grisha yeager was
indoctrinating his young son zeke you
have to pretend to be loyal to marley so
you can become one of the elden titan
warriors but secretly you have to be
anti-marley steal the founding titan and
use it to lead the aldean revolution
this was too much pressure for yangzik
and he ended up turning his parents in
whoops criminal aldians are taken to
parodies where they're turned into
titans so that's where the titans are
coming from it's a punishment for them
and they serve as guards to keep the
island aliens inside their walls but
grisha yeager is saved by his guard who
turns out is a secret eldin in the
resistance too and somehow through
unknown means he has the power of one of
the nine titans it's the one aaron gets
the attack titan he's like hey man i
have the same basic plan as you but i
can't do it myself anyone who gets one
of the nine titans only lives for 13
years and my time's almost up you gotta
take this one from me infiltrate the
walls steal the founding titan and save
all aliens and so he did that's the
story we know and passed it on to his
son aaron but wait a sec the founding
titan only works if you have royal blood
which aaron doesn't but aaron figures
out why it worked that one time when he
touched this specific titan because that
titan was his dad's first wife who had
the royal blood so now we finally know
mostly what is going on and so
relatively quickly our humans finally
eradicate all the titans on their island
they are finally free except they're
kind of not though because right across
the sea is an entire world of people
that think they're devils and want to
kill them kind of a bummer and so season
four begins four years later over in
marley we follow a new bunch of kids
they're the top elden warrior candidates
to inherit one of the titans the main
ones are confident girl gobby and her
friend falco now marley's at war with
someone and we get to see their titans
in action by the way emir was executed
they gave her titan to a new guy its
proper name is the jaw titan and they
use the normal mindless titans pure
titans as weapons too for unknown
reasons probably related to his royal
blood zeke has the power to transform
them with a yell and oh skydiving titan
bombardment uh that should probably be a
war crime anyway as we get to know these
people we see they really aren't bad
most of these aliens think that fighting
for marley is the right thing to do and
rhina also who we've thought of as an
enemy but is a decent guy he and his
crew thought they were making their
country proud as they were shipped off
as kids on an undercover genocide
mission anyway now with the recent war 1
it's time to focus on parody again they
have a big event to announce they're
finally going to go wipe out those elden
devils but one of them is closer than
they think it's long-haired adult aaron
yeager he and ryan have a chat it's like
i'm so sorry man and aaron's like yeah i
understand and i'm sorry too because
aaron's here on his own mission oh titan
attack most of the marlin high command
is gathered right there so aaron takes
him out in one fell swoop but a titan
warrior we haven't met yet is here to
fight back they call it the warhammer
titan because it can use its hardening
power to like make up hammer but aaron's
not alone mikas is here too with a whole
bunch of thunder spears boom aaron eats
that girl and takes the power of the
warhammer titan now too yes a bunch of
scouts are here ready to fight in the
modern world it's a massive fight all
the marley titans join in but our crew
with their odm gear are deadly but now
mika says like aaron what have you done
you just killed thousands of civilians
and our new kid gabi having seen a bunch
of her friends die swears vengeance just
like aaron did all those years ago our
crew escapes on their new airship but
gabi's not letting them get away she and
falco get aboard and shoots the first
person she sees which is no not sasha
she was so nice just love to eat anyway
turns out this preemptive attack was
just aaron yeager's idea the military
told him not to but him starting it
forced their hand and aaron had a
co-conspirator his half-brother zeke
going back a few years to see how he got
here our people captured one of the
marlin scout chips but the tall girl in
command here is like hey we're part of
the ld resistance against marley we want
to be friends and believe it or not zeke
the beast titan is with us too so they
helped our wall people get modern
technology and meet some allies out in
the world this country was allies with
the old alien empire and turns out their
queen went behind the walls too and it's
mikasa's ancestor so she's a princess
and speaking of princesses in case it
matters historia is pregnant the plan
was supposed to be to reintroduce
themselves to the world in a peaceful
manner hey we aren't devils but aaron
yeager apparently disagreed he doesn't
talk much anymore to actually explain
himself but it seems like he believed
the only way they'll ever really be safe
is if they wipe out everyone else most
of the military including aaron's
friends all think this attack was a bad
idea but there's a lot of them who think
that aaron had the right of it and are
ready to conquer the world as the new
alien empire and soon aaron breaks
himself out of prison to lead this group
called the jaegerists and aaron yeager
has grown up from an annoying angry
yelling kid to a badass stone-cold rebel
leader so the jaegerists take over the
government and aaron finally talks to
his friends who are like what the heck
are you doing man but aaron still
doesn't explain his motivations he is
really mean to his friends though makes
mikasa cry time will tell if aaron has
really become such a douchebag or if he
has some secret plot we know the first
part of his plan though is to meet up
with zeke who's being held prisoner in
the forest by captain levi and a whole
squad of soldiers we learned that it's
zeke's spinal fluid that if aliens
ingest it he can turn him into titans
somewhat under his control it turns out
the wine his friends brought from marley
were spiked with his juices so now he
shouts and turns all his guards into
titans but not captain levi he doesn't
drink and handly takes down the beast
titan again he ties him to a
thunderspear and makes him explain his
double double cross super secret plan
zeke's mentor was the beast titan before
him who knew all about titan lore and he
learned the founding titan with royal
blood can do more than alter eldian
memories it can alter their physiology
so zeke who witnessed all the alien
suffering doesn't agree with his dad
that they should rise up he thinks it
would be best if they just disappeared
apparently his real plan is to take the
founding titan and use it to sterilize
all aldians so they and titans will
disappear from the earth for now though
he escapes by blowing himself up along
with captain levi who will hopefully be
fine zeke's titan powers will eventually
heal him and he escapes once again but
now aaron gets a surprise visit from the
girl who is the cart titan but she's
like hey man i'm on your side and
there's something outside you've got to
see so she lures aaron out there but
it's a double cross cause the jaw
tightens under him he misses his shot
though does not get aaron so aaron
transforms just as marley and airships
are flying in this is their
counter-attack who will win this final
battle what is aaron's real plan find
out in the final chapter of attack on
titan
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member